everybody welcome back to planet coaster
and specifically welcome back to the
Japanese garden projects it's been a
while especially for this map but
something that convinced me to give it
another try is the new update which is
coming out which is update 1.8 which is
the world's fair updates and among other
things which are very exciting and
actually includes an asian-themed pack
and this is something which a couple of
people have already mentioned for me is
kind of interesting because I did a lot
of Asian scenery builds in planet
coaster so far mostly Chinese and
Japanese style roofs etc that I had to
build completely myself and now all of
these items have been added into the
game itself so in a way it could kind of
feel like some time that I ended up
wasting a long time ago where I could
have just waited for this update to come
out and you know finally get this thing
without having to build all of it myself
but for me it also just made it much
more interesting to try these pieces and
see how much they really live up to what
I was hoping to get out of them and see
if it's really gonna make it obsolete to
make your own roofs the painful way that
I used to now I don't want to leave you
hanging when it comes to what opinion I
actually have on this set I'll come back
to this a little bit later but I think
the Asian piece are actually really
brilliant and I was really positively
surprised by how fitting and flexible
they actually are but before that is
there's a bit of an explanation I
suppose that I need to give about what's
going on on the screen right now so for
a few minutes now I have been trying to
pack all of the items that I want to use
and have used for this build so far into
one custom tag so something that's been
added in this update which I am really
looking forward to or technically I've
already tried here but since the pack is
only coming out later something which i
think is really worth looking forward to
is the option to make your own custom
tags so in the past this has been very
often requested by people because it
just makes it a lot easier if you can
separate
all of these scenarios and war items and
everything else based on what kind of
theme or maybe even what kind of project
you're going for so in this case I
wanted to sort all kinds of objects that
I have used and can use for a Japanese
theme into one particular set so I met
the custom tank for a Japanese theme so
I fit all of the Chinese roofs which
I'll be using as well as the Japanese
wall sets as well as all kinds of random
scenery shrubs trees and rock work into
that one set all for this particular
Park so I don't really have to look for
some of the smaller pieces anymore and I
can also remember exactly what kind of
pieces I've used before so we don't
really get inconsistent so yeah this is
an option which has been requested a lot
and actually really liked it I think
it's been implemented pretty much
exactly how you'd want it to be you
could just select a piece and then add
it to your custom tag now I'm already
kind of running behind here here I'm
already starting the build itself so to
give you a little bit of a background on
this I got the early review build so of
course I felt kind of obliged it's
actually make some videos about this and
give a bit of a review as usual also I
don't really like to do those kind of
videos where I just kind of list off
what's been added in the new updates
you'll just see that eventually and
there are plenty of people who do that
sort of thing so instead of that I just
kind of want to pick one of my own ideas
and/or themes and see how much you can
actually get it to work with the new
update considering all of the new pieces
so in this case I wanted to open the up
the Japanese garden again which I
haven't opened in quite a while and try
all of the new Asian pieces and
something that I decided to do to do
that is a Japanese castle build and this
is something that I've always wanted to
try but never ended up doing because it
used to be way too complicated you need
so many different roof pieces for this
and so many custom pieces that you'd
probably end up with thousands of
objects in one building if you were to
do it the old way so it's something that
I never really quite got to but with
these new roofs
it's an amazing opportunity to finally
try a Japanese Castle while also testing
the roofs at the same time so one of my
biggest worries about these things is
that Asian roofs are very hard to make
modular because there is already a
difference between Japanese Chinese
styles and especially Korean styles all
kinds of buildings have different rates
of like curvature of the roofs on the
sides so it's really hard to build a
modular set for this unlike something
like maybe a Bavarian style where all of
the roofs are more or less the same from
building to building and they have the
same angle throughout now something
interesting that I thought which I
didn't think of before then actually
turns out to be kind of good solution to
that problem is that the roofs
themselves they were quite modular in
terms of how you put them together
there's a bunch of different curvatures
and sizes for the roofs so they're a
little bit more flexible than I expected
them beforehand because I expected these
roofs to just be full tile grid style
roofs with one curving corner piece and
that would be about it
but as you can see from a menu there are
quite a few variations depending on what
size or what curvature you want and of
course you can leave the curves
completely out of it as well and just
have a simple tiled roof so it's
something that I'm actually quite happy
with judging from the castle so far the
only thing that I do kind of miss if I
can give a bit of a review is a curving
roof piece which isn't a corner piece
for all of the corner pieces this set
works out brilliantly but there isn't
really a roof piece which works for a
Gables there isn't really that sort of
slight curving roof piece aside from
that though it works quite well and
there's actually even these gable pieces
for the size of the roof and the
decorations on that as well which you
can see on the front here it's the
lights part that I just put down there
so all-in-all it's a set which is
surprisingly versatile for the not even
that many pieces that it has
whereas the preview build that frontier
used for their trailer of this new
updates included a Chinese tile build I
was also kind of skeptical whether it
would actually be able to work out for
Japanese buildings as well but from this
build at least I am a little bit of a
layman but as far as I can tell it
actually works out really well for a
Japanese builds as well really the major
differences as I've explained in some
earlier videos is really in the textures
and the colors because where Chinese
buildings use a lot of stone and a lot
of colors things like that Japanese
buildings are much more simple they
don't really use painting on the
exterior of their buildings except for
red painting in some cases they use a
lot more wood so it's a very different
type of like color scheme and set of
textures that you get from these
buildings but when it comes to the
general shape and where they come from
Japanese architecture is obviously very
much influenced by Chinese architecture
so coming from the same base it's very
possible to create Japanese buildings
from these new pieces so yeah I gotta
say whichever artists worked on this
good job I'm actually very happy with
these items obviously there is more to
this update pack and in fact it's a kind
of pack then I've wanted for a very long
time this isn't something that I've
talked a lot about but I've probably
casually named dropped it a few times
during the fantasy valley series but the
world Fair's especially the world fairs
around 1900 I think also 1889 in Paris
and these were their world Fair's that
you could see for the first time the
Statue of Liberty and the Eiffel Tower
and all kinds of Parisian buildings that
are now very famous these were my
biggest inspirations for the longest
time not really these buildings in
particular but a lot of the buildings at
the time since this was really an area
of or an error of are Nouveau and all
kinds of very decorated building types
just before modernism started kicking in
and building started getting modern so
I have enormous folders on my computer
of all the pictures I could find on the
Internet of the the expedition the
Exposition Universelle at the Paris my
pronunciation is terrible I'm sorry
about that
but yeah this has been something that's
been such an influence for what I've
been doing and really an inspiration as
well for me that it's really cool to see
a pack with a very similar kind of theme
fantasy valley in fact in the first
place was inspired by these kind of
things and I was trying to sort of
incorporate that whole idea into a park
sort of happy valley style but yeah
that's something in the past and also
know I'll never get back to fantasy
Valley I'm sorry it's just way too
outdated by now but yeah basically
that's it about the pack so there's all
kinds of different countries in there as
well there are some Moorish architecture
which i think is very interesting and I
might use to get back to the old Moorish
intamin which I only released two
episodes of right now I think so that's
all that's something very interesting
there are some more European style
elements in there as well there's a
whole set of Bavarian architecture which
is very interesting now we don't have to
do all of our timber work ourselves
anymore
and just all kinds of new interesting
features there's the become a boomerang
coaster or I'm saying boomerang coaster
but it's the vakama motor bike coaster I
was kind of getting it confused with a
booster bike over there for some reason
which is actually yeah it is the booster
bike version of the motorbike coaster
it's not the drone version I believe
that has a different track or maybe I'm
slightly off on that I'm gonna have to
check on that later but in any case it's
a vakama
motor bike coaster of which booster bike
in toverland is the first ones that's
how I often refer to it so that's a
really cool addition to the pack as well
and then there's all kinds of other
gameplay elements which are being
changed as well we can finally trigger
doors we can set custom tags for stuff
obviously so there's a lot of check out
in the pack it should be coming out
tomorrow so stay tuned for that and
today those should be
lots of other videos likely from other
youtubers who have gotten the preview
build as well anyway let me catch up on
the build a little bit so this is a
Japanese castle and as such it stands on
a bit of a rocky base a lot of these
castles stand of a very tall base also
they're very often also built on a hill
as well so there are very visual icons
unfortunately I don't really have a good
hill to build it on here and they didn't
really want to go as far as to build my
own hill so I'm just building it on this
stone foundation to kind of stay with
the theme of a Japanese castle and also
make sure that it's kind of towering
over the trees of the garden in the back
of it here because something that I
wanted to do with the garden for a long
time also and I couldn't really figure
out how to do it was what they often
call shuck care if I pronounced it
correctly the key at the end should just
give you a longer air sound but yeah
it's it's basically it's firm in
Japanese gardening and general
aesthetics of borrowing scenery from
some other place so a lot of Japanese
gardens will kind of use their
surroundings to an advantage now
obviously a lot of the colonists that
have shown in Tokyo before in the video
that kind of started off this whole
series they don't really work like that
anymore because a lot of their
traditional surroundings have been more
or less destroyed by all of the
skyscrapers and other kind of in an
awkward position where the little
enclaves of an old natural environment
but if you go to gardens outside of that
gardens for instance in Kyoto or nada or
completely other places in Japan there
are these gardens that kind of use the
natural to metro terrain around them
like the natural mountains and hills as
a kind of backdrop and sort of draw them
into the garden and use them interviews
that you have within the garden and
there you can do this with all of the
built environments around the gardens as
well so a lot of gardens will use maybe
a nearby temple and their pagoda
or some kind of existing build in the
vicinity of the garden as a backdrop for
the garden to give it a more interesting
aesthetic so that's something I wanted
to try over here as well so while I'm
not really going to decorate the base of
this castle too much it's not something
that you're really supposed to see from
the ground it is something to give you a
backdrop as you're in the garden to
expand the landscape of the kind in a
little bit beyond the borders the garden
itself so yeah I was messing for a very
long time with what position this
building should have whether I wanted to
have it on this side of the garden or on
the other side and how tall it should
really be just because the only reason
that this building is here is to be in
some of the sight lines within the
garden so you can see the castle in the
background as a kind of borrowed scenery
and just give more Flair to walking
around and the gun in itself so yeah
that's basically it we're getting to a
stage now where the building is looking
more and more finished this was
definitely one of those builds where I
started off with very rough idea and
composition of what I wanted to building
to be like and at the beginning I
thought it was extremely ugly
I really wasn't happy with it so that
kind of got me worried at the start but
in the end I think it works out fine all
right and a lot of the times with builds
like this as you're building it sort of
starts getting better over time
that's definitely what I felt here oh
and something that I think is worth
noting about this as well is that it
just takes way less time to do these
kinds of builds when you actually have
all of the pieces available obviously
the results is something that matters
quite a bit but to me it also kind of
matters how much time I really have to
spend building something and with your
pieces it would just take hours upon
hours actually make all of these pieces
yourself and here I'm more or less just
jumped into the game after just
sketching a very basic idea of what I
wanted to do and how I wanted to do it
and pretty much just built this in under
three hours
well that is excluding the amount of
times that I started rebuilding things
just kind of was spinning the camera
around looking at my stuff so yeah all
in all it's something that really cuts
time quite a lot when it comes to built
like these so yeah I'm really happy with
the new scenery it's definitely
something they had had it would have
liked to have a long time ago but there
is no way you can complain about that
really it's just really cool to see it
finally be in the game and to see some
love for some of the scenery sets that
we haven't really gotten so far like
Asian is the theme that we've been
missing but also Arabic style in this
case Moorish architecture is a general
direction of architecture that we've
been kind of missing in the game and
it's nice to finally see some
appreciation for these styles so yeah
maybe I'll get back to Shakira and
actually finish some of the buildings in
there as well but I do have to say that
was originally my plan to do in this
weekend as well I just didn't really
have enough time for it if anything I'm
also cutting it dangerously close with
making this episode so we'll see how
much time I really have for that that
said I know it's been a long time but
I've got a Jaeger horn episode coming up
really close to this upload dates so
yeah I'll be following this up with more
stuff soon enough anyway thank you guys
for watching I hope you thought it was
interesting to check out a bit of a
preview of the updates and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]